- This is the one where it falls down.
It's gonna fall down.
Tower of peas are gonna fall down.
Hi, guys.
We are Haim.
We are at Buzzfeed.
And we are about to play giant Jenga.
(heavenly chorus)
Giddy up.
Good on my side.
Oh, woop, woop, no, no, no.
- Wait.
You did it.
- Oh, gosh.
It says dare.
(laughter)
- I think I know where
you're going with this
and I don't appreciate it.
- That was my impression of Danielle.
(laughter)
- Goddamit.
- This is a great--
What is this technique called?
- It's called tactics.
Truth.
- Okay.
- Randomly in Studio City,
there was a yard sale
and we have been known to
frequent many a yard sale.
- Yes.
- Did not know that I was going
to a Clean House yard sale.
Saw the cameras and I
was like there's no way.
There's no way.
- Also, we loved that show.
- Oh, I love that show.
- The fact that they came to
the valley, 818 was so happy.
Let me tell you.
- Oh, this is a great tactic.
I'm gonna steal this too.
- Truth.
- I'm really glad I did not get that one.
- I mean.
- Wow, I'm really glad
I did not get that one.
- I mean like, right now.
Like, how'd you know?
- What'll it be?
- I think it would have to be Levi's.
Gotta go.
- Just sayin'.
Truth.
The song Something To Tell You
on our new record Something To Tell You.
The title track if you will.
(laughter)
- The Wire is still super fun to play live
and we wrote it in 2008.
- Yeah.
- So, I've been playing
it since I was like--
- Yeah.
- I don't even know.
- Comin' up on its 10 year anniversary.
- Yeah, comin' up.
- Dare.
- Got a dare.
We got a dare.
- Kay, ready?
Well, first put that on.
- Okay.
- I'm a little tea pot.
And then tip the tea.
Move your arm in.
Wait, I have to position it.
There we go.
One, two--
(clicking noise)
- We rehearsed from two to six
in the morning Sunday
A.M., Sunday morning.
The street wasn't completely blocked off.
- There was just a little puzzle
piece of Ventar Boulevard.
- Yeah, a little puzzle
piece of Ventar Boulevard
and then from six o' clock in
the morning til eight o'clock
in the morning it was
completely shut down,
this little two block radius.
We did 15 takes.
- Yes.
- Cause it's all one shot.
- Just so you know, everybody
wants to leave like,
after hours and we're
gonna be playing this game
for 45 more minutes.
Okay.
- Alana is an expert baker.
- That is pretty shocking.
Shocking news, you heard it hear first.
Alright, here we go.
- Wow.
- It's getting tall here.
Okay.
It's getting hard now.
- Okay.
- Here we go and--
- Yes.
- We had a sing along on the way
up to Glastenbury the other day.
- Oh, gosh.
- It's the--
Do you know the song Scat Man?
(drumming sounds)
- This is really scary.
- You got this.
- I'm walking out of this room right now.
I'm walking--
This is--
Oh, oh!
- Lifeline.
- (phone sounds) Hello?
Taylor Hanson I would marry.
I would shag Zach and I would--
Isaac and I, we're both the oldest.
- Y'all are friends.
- We'd be homies.
- Yeah, that's great.
Follow it.
- Nice.
- Follow it.
- Everyone in this room wants to go home.
This will never end.
Here we go, ready?
Este Haim, you are my oldest sister.
- Accurate.
- And when I need help, I
come to you for boyfriends.
- Of course you do.
(laughter)
- Este Haim, what would I do?
I don't know, it's really true.
- Yep.
- Cause you're the best,
the best in the west
and I love you.
Hey, hey.
- There was one--
- Este and the Haims.
- I don't think the band is
gonna survive this Jenga game.
- I'm scared.
- You're fine.
- Truth.
It's definitely a collaborative effort.
Este definitely on our new
video for Want You Back,
Este came up with this move.
- This one.
- Francis and the lights helped us.
Which is, we love you Francis.
And also, our friend Ian
helped us and it was a collab.
But, the walking part--
- You did a really good
turn and you spotted.
Yeah, so when you spot,
it's like when you turn.
- Danielle is gonna
knock this over right now
and I swear--
- I'm not, just trust me.
- I will freak out.
- When you turn, you keep your
head, you look at one spot--
- And then you flick it.
- And then you--
- Flick it.
- There you go.
Will this game ever end?
(laughter)
Oh, M, G.
- Is that allowed?
- It counts, it counts,
it counts, it counts.
(laughter)
- We fought it together.
- We all got it here.
We all got here together.
- Okay, are we doing it this way?
- Yeah.
- One, two, three.
(screaming)
- For a second, we
thought it was gonna stay.
- You guys, we did it.
- We did it.
- You guys, I love you.
I love you.
- Can like, us and Ladylike
do like a Jenga off?
I'm obsessed with those girls, by the way.
- Yeah, can we do that next time?